bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 13
janvier merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
votre actualité locale
chaque jour entourés de nos invités tout
de suite les titres de cette édition les
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine ont présenté ensemble
hier soir leurs voeux l'occasion pour
pierre bédier et patrick devedjian
d'annoncer officiellement leur projet de
fusion la société vélopolis condamné par
le tribunal de grande instance de
versailles en cause l'action intentée
contre les citoyens et les citoyennes
qui avait contesté le permis de
construire du vélodrome national de
montigny le bretonneux en plateau pierre
déjean membres d assigner vous en
parlera enfin voisins le bretonneux
lance sa mutuelle deux villages une
complémentaire santé négocié par la
ville pour ses habitants et ses employés
reportage à suivre sur cette nouvelle
initiative
et c'est certainement la fin de
l'opération pour le petit robot fila est
installé sur la planète sourit il ne se
réveillera probablement pas dimanche une
manoeuvre de la dernière chance a été
tenté pour faire bouger fila et sans
succès ce petit robot laboratoire qui
vit sur la partie non éclairée de la
comète
depuis novembre 2014 n'a pas communiquer
avec la terre depuis le 9 janvier
dernier
son sort sera fixé à la fin du mois
d'ici fin janvier les conditions
extérieures deviendront trop pose-t-il
pour sa survie
plusieurs chercheurs du latmos le
laboratoire atmosphères milieux
observations spatiales situé à
l'université de 50 ans une avaient
participé à cette opération yvelines et
hauts-de-seine réunis en un seul
département c'était le sujet de toutes
les discussions et hier soir à la
cérémonie des voeux 2016 du département
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine à
marnes-la-coquette les présidents des
conseils départementaux pierre bédier et
patrick devedjian ont tenu à rassembler
les voeux de leur département pour
annoncer officiellement leur souhait de
fusionner les deux territoires
les élus et les hauts de seine pourrait
donc bientôt n'être qu'un seul et même
département avec un objectif
mutualisation et économie
les précisions de williams elle qui
était sur place c'est le cas de mon
premier voeu
que la france se porte mieux
économiquement et socialement bien sûr
mais aussi et surtout au regard de
l'unité c'était le thème de cette soirée
de cérémonie de voeux 2016 les
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine ont mutualisé leurs
cérémonies
symbole de cette fusion voulue par les
présidents des conseils départementaux
des deux territoires
'l'annonce fait devant une salle comble
d'élus député-maire et personnalités
sportives comme laurent blanc ou le
racing métro c'est de faire de la
mutualisation compte en faisant des
choses qu on faisait chacun de notre
côté là en les faisant ensemble ça
coûtera moins cher
un exemple c'est pour ça qu'on commence
par les routes les appels d'offres on
comptera concerneront deux départements
donc forcément les entreprises pour les
avoirs seront obligés de baisser leurs
prix et cette mutualisation de générer
des économies qu'ils vont être affectés
à modérer la pression fiscale et à
financer le développement économique
il n'y a pas de politique sociale
possible sans développement économique
plus qu'un trait d'union un projet
d'alliance visant à créer un seul et
même département
un calendrier a déjà été annoncé nous
commençons le 5 février par deux
délibérations conques
dante
du conseil départemental
crissement public interdépartemental
dans lequel nous allons réunir
progressivement nos services un conseil
dont la présidence devrait être prise
par patrick devidjian réunissant les 88
conseillers des deux assemblées le
gouvernement récolte ce qu'il a semé
il a créé une métropole qui était ni
fait ni à faire et qui coupait la région
ile de france dans une frontière qui
n'avait aucun sens il n'y a pas trop de
frontières entre rueil malmaison et la
celle-saint-cloud entre clamart et
vélizy donc la vérité c'est que la
réplique des hauts-de-seine et des
yvelines aller le jeton une solution
pour pallier les baisses de dotations
globales de fonctionnement mais aussi
contrer le projet du grand paris qui
n'inclut et que les départements de la
petite couronne
reste encore à attendre l'autorisation
de l'état pour une fusion qui devrait
commencer à se dessiner dès le 5 février
l'opposition du conseil départemental
des hauts-de-seine quant à elles
contestent ce projet y réclame son
abandon et pierre bédier s'est également
exprimé sur le budget du département des
yvelines je vous propose de l'écouter
toujours micro de william l ça a été
déjà annoncée avant débat d'orientation
budgétaire dont vous aurez la réponse
précise à l'endroit des mérous y aura
des hausses fiscales provisoire nous
l'espérons
puisque si l'état nous rend l'argent
qu'il nous prend naturellement ça
repartira immédiatement baisses d'impôts
le département des yvelines le
département qui dépensent le moins par
habitant
ce qu'on appelle les dépenses de
fonctionnement et vient on continuera à
être celui qui dépense le moins mais
malheureusement l'état nous prend 200
millions d'euros
si nous verrons demain je promets la
baisse des impôts immédiate et les
budgets primitifs a été néanmoins
préparé fin décembre 2015 les élus
yvelinois se réuniront le vendredi 22
janvier en séance plénière à l'hôtel du
département pour voter le budget le
budget définitif de 2016 et nous
recevons en plateau pierre déjean nombre
d assigner bonsoir et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors le tribunal de grande instance de
versailles a condamné vélopolis à verser
1500 euros à chacun des 6 a signé au
titre de dommages et intérêts pour
procédure abusive
alors que le police a été contactée je
le précise également pour s'exprimer en
plateau mais ils n'ont pas souhaité
donner suite à notre demande
alors qu'hier deux jours si nous
revenons un petit peu sur la sphère
vélopolis c'est une victoire forcément
pour les assigner car cela faisait
depuis 2009 que vous bâtissez alors oui
en fait nous battons sur le sujet du et
drôme depuis 2009 mais ses 10 des
destinations n'est arrivé qu'en 2011 et
autant les procédures auprès du
trimestre à thé fonds était de notre
initiative celle au tribunal de grande
instance donc l'assignation et de
l'initiative de vélo police alors vous
protestez donc forcément contre contre
ce vélodrome et aussi contre les actions
intentées à vélo police contre vous
contre les est cynique ce que vous
pouvez nous rappeler rapidement
commencer la simple déroulée en tout cas
pour la dernière dans les procès alors
le dernier procès donc celui du très
bien le grand instance est intimement
lié au précédent qui était attribué la
strate if
puisque le tribunal passe ratée à
trancher sur notre recours en annulation
tout le met de construire au mois de
juillet je crois 2014 or vélopolis nous
reprochait c'était une des raisons de
leur assignation de faire une procédure
abusive de ne pas être
suffisamment proches qui voilà ce qu'on
peut trouver le brome je cherchais le
terme juridique
voilà oui voisins mais c'est sa fade à
part ne pas avoir intérêt à agir comme
ça bon alors après boy toujours
baratiner sur le lan fumée truc mais le
fait simple le simple fait que le
tribunal a statué signifie effectivement
pas que nous étions tout à fait légitime
et que nous avions toutes tes capacités
juridiques agir en plus le tribunal
s'étaient fa reconnu que nos arguments
étaient des arguments urbanistique et
qu'ils étaient fondées à la règle était
fondée le tribunal n'a pas jugé qu' ils
étaient suffisants pour annuler le
permis de construire
mais il faut remarquer une chose c'est
que notre initiative nous n'avons pas
été condamnés certes le tribunal a
tranché en notre défaveur mais sans
condamnation
c'est bien que effectivement la plainte
de vélo police concernant de cette
procédure abusive et de le fait on n
était pas apte à ester en outre la
stratégie
sa tombe est tout seul voilà donc bien
le tribunal de grande instance cette
fois ci donc à statuer le 8 décembre
eva il d'abord il a commencé par
constater que le trimestre ont été de ce
côté-là avait tranché et nous avait
donné raison
il a constaté d'autre part que ben sur
les dires de velaux police bah c'était
que des dires mais il n'y avait eu une
âme n'ai aucun élément probant donc tout
simplement que leur procédure était
effectivement uniquement destiné à nous
contraindre à nous faire retirer notre
notre recours contre le permis de
construire est donc que c'est eux qui
avaient engagé une procédure abusive
c'est d'ailleurs marqué dans l'acte du
jugement
la procédure est sévère de ce côté-là
été reconnu comme abusives le vélodrome
est là du coup est ce qu'il ya une suite
pour ce combat ce qu'est une seat pour
les assigner ou du coup votre action
s'arrêtait ici maintenant je vais dire
que elle s'arrête maintenant en toute
bonne justice et heureusement que c'est
comme ça chaque parti à droite se
rappelle donc aujourd'hui le 13 janvier
nous n'avons pas de connaissance de 7
deux sets d'une action de ce genre nous
évidemment nous avons décidé de ne pas
faire appel mais entendu levé le police
est toujours à la poursuite de le faire
lorsqu une date qui est tout à fait un
peu incertaine parce que après ça
entraîne des histoires de procédure mais
pour moi d'après ce que j'ai compris de
la loi c'est le délai dépassé mais je
suis pas juriste donc j'ai pu commettre
une erreur d'interprétation
enfin on va attendre encore un peu s'ils
ne font pas appel ben oui ça se termine
bref bonne notre avocate va aller voir
l'avocat de police demander le paiement
est un terrain mois passés eux c'est
purement administratif ou un truc pour
nous pour nous j'ai terminé c'est la fin
justement de cette histoire un peu de
vélo drame est justement d assigner
merci à pierre déjean d'être venu merci
vous nous en parler sur le plateau et si
la neige n'est pas encore tombée dans le
département comme chaque hiver le plan
hivernal et mise en oeuvre par le
service de la voirie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mis en place
mi novembre il est actif jusqu'à la fin
du mois de mars
stock de sélys elles sont les principaux
dispositifs du plan de déneigement celui
ci s'applique pour la dernière année aux
sept communes de l'ancien agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines avant de
s'étendre dès 2016 à plaisir coignières
maurepas villepreux et les
clayes-sous-bois un reportage signé
sephora namani et fanny bourdon
compétence facultative pour les
agglomérations la gestion de la voirie
est prise en charge par saint quentin en
yvelines
le service hivernal organise chaque
année un plan de déneigement du 15
novembre au 31 mars
cette mission est confiée à un
prestataire extérieur
le but étant de rendre donc un niveau de
service
le plus rapide possible sur les voirie
d'intérêt communautaire qui ont qui sont
donc des voies de liaison entre les
communes et qui également le plus
souvent tu accueilles un trafic de
transport en commun
donc il faut être très réactif pour
après pouvoir desservir également les
gars
et puis tous les équipements publics une
veille météorologique est assurée chaque
jour pendant cette période par le
service de la voirie de saint quentin en
yvelines
aidés par les prévisionnistes de météo
france cette analyse permet de
déclencher le plan de déneigement pour
les épisodes glissant ou neigeux
anticipées en cas d'intempéries imprévus
les services aucune heure pour réagir il
ya donc neuf saleuses une dixième donc
de secours lorsqu'il vend tellement il y
aurait une avarie donc sur les véhicules
et donc normalement dont les deux
niveaux de service de le destiner rers
doivent être réalisés donc sur une durée
maximale de trois heures la
problématique c'est toujours la
circulation pendant les heures de pointe
les saleuses peuvent pas rouler au pas
comme il faudrait donc ces
problématiques entre 8h et 10h et
ensuite entre 16h et 18h avec les
saleuses on a un stock de sel de 1200
tonnes en début de saison
parmi les dispositifs également des bacs
à sable long des chaussées et le
déneigement des trottoirs et pistes
cyclables
cette année le plan hivernal ne concerne
que les sept communes historique de
l'ancienne agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
mais dès 2016 celui ci intégrera les
cinq nouvelles communes et l'orientation
scolaire et professionnelle se pose
souvent de plus en plus tôt pour aider
les jeunes la mairie de montigny le
bretonneux organisé hier mardi 12
janvier au pôle jeunesse
la 6ème édition de la nuit des métiers
et de l'orientation
regardez ce reportage signé sephora
namani et mélanie poker intégrer la
police c'est le soin de jonathan 16 ans
élève en seconde générale
il s'est rendu hier mardi 12 janvier à
la 6e édition de la nuit des métiers de
l'orientation de montigny le bretonneux
je sais déjà utilisé plus d'affaires
pour ren traitement dans la police j'ai
du coup je vais reposer des questions et
ensuite prendre une décision pour la
première donc continent
en professionnel faut effectivement être
autonome pour aller chercher
l'information
1 on vous donne effectivement des
indications disons qu'il ya tel forum ou
tel salon tout ça mais pour vraiment
gros face à des marches à vient vraiment
de la personne et de l'enfant d'élèves
en vain mot et les paroles qui
accompagne en même temps définir son
projet d'orientation peut être source
d'interrogation pour les étudiants du
collège à l'université pour les
renseigner sur les parcours d'études
possibles les filières les métiers leurs
débouchés
le pôle jeunesse de montigny s'est
associé à yviers d'information jeunesse
et le ciap centre d'information et
d'orientation professionnelle
il ya un premier test lui faire faire
avec un ordinateur où on va lui donner
les orientations et après on va avoir un
comment un entretien avec une personne
qui veulent orienter en fonction de ce
qui ce qu'ils détiennent les forums ses
six plus localisée est longue les
parents ont peut-être plus de temps pour
parler il est conseillé
orientation c'est plus personnalisée
plus individualisé peut-être grand salon
après ce premier contact
les étudiants pourront revenir chercher
de la documentation pour approfondir
leur projet au pôle jeunesse de montigny
le bretonneux qui désormais héberge
yvelines information jeunesse 78 dans le
cadre de la prévention des usages
d'internet trois établissements
scolaires de plaisir le collège blaise
pascal le collège guillaume apollinaire
et le lycée jean vilar se sont associés
pour mener une action d'information en
direction des parents pour nous en
parler ce soir en plein d'objets en
plateau janyk ryan mon soir vous êtes la
principale du collège blaise pascal
alors vous organisez aussi avec les
autres établissements
cette rencontre avec l'association
e-enfance également elle aura lieu donc
demain jeudi 14 janvier à 19 heures tel
un petit peu l'objectif de cette revue
cette rencontre justement donc c'est la
deuxième rencontre de ce type que nous
organisons la dernière l'année dernière
c'était au lycée jean vilar
cette année c'est dans nos locaux donc
l'objectif c'est de permettre aux
parents d'être mieux informés sur les
utilisations que font leurs enfants de
leur téléphone portable qui au-delà est
en général bien plus que l'utilisation
de téléphone et une utilisation de
messagerie de réseaux sociaux instagram
snap chatte qui parfois déborde dans les
couloirs des établissements scolaires ou
juste à l'extérieur des établissements
scolaires alors justement vous avez mis
en place donc cette rencontre parce que
vous étiez vous-même d'antan peut-être
principale ou avec les autres
principales eux confrontés à des
problèmes à cause des réseaux sociaux
oui il nous arrive parfois d'avoir à
gérer des conflits entre élèves qui
naissent ou qui
qui se développe book dégénère suite
affectivement d utilisation abusive de
ces réseaux sociaux des images qui sont
transportés via ses réseaux sociaux mais
déformés et puis les parents ne sont
assez démunis parce que soit ils ne
savent pas que leurs enfants font cet
usage soit une se rendent pas compte des
proportions que ça peut prendre et
vernon et donc nous souhaitions que les
parents puissent mieux comprendre ce qui
se passe parfois à leur insu et être
informés aussi de leurs responsabilités
parce que finalement c'est un espace où
les adultes ont peu de contrôle et ont
peu de visibilité par rapport à ce que
font leurs enfants ou même ce que font
les élèves justement sur ces réseaux
sociaux
certains parents sont informés d'autres
et la majorité le sont beaucoup moins
est-ce que du coup il faut que les
parents soient informés et qu'ils
accompagnent justement leurs enfants
dans l'utilisation alors que peut-être
ils ne savent pas forcément aussi bien
les utiliser que les plus jeunes c'est
ce que nous pensons et c'est pour ça que
nous avons souhaité renouveler cette
information qui a déjà été fait comme je
vous l'aï dit et qui a rencontré un
certain succès l'année dernière il ya eu
des demandes de la part de nos
fédérations de parents d'élèves pour
renouveler cette soirée d'information sa
compagne pour le guide lycée le collège
part d'un guillaume apollinaire une
un temps d'information dans les classes
de 5e pour le collège blaise pascal un
temps d'information qui aura lieu plus
tard dans l'année scolaire aussi pour
les classes de 5ème avec la même
association et enfance et j'espère que
ça aura un impact positif sur et les
élèves et les parents parce que parfois
les les enfants écoutent bien mais ne
transmettent pas toujours donc du coup
toute l'année il va y avoir enfin au
cours de l'année il va y avoir justement
cette session d'information demain
précisément ça va être un des basses
avec un échange comment ça va se
dérouler un petit peu je pense que nous
suivrons le même programme que l'année
dernière c'est à dire qu'il y aura
d'abord une présentation faite par
l'animateur dit enfance et à tout moment
les personnes présentes peuvent poser
des questions et donc de ces questions
laisse d'autres questions parfois qui
permettent effectivement d'enrichir les
discussions et de donner des
informations plus précises et des
références auxquelles les parents
pourront aller eux-mêmes retrouver pour
lesquels ils pourront retrouver pardon
des renseignements plus précis sur le
site dix enfants ce qui est très
facilement accessible aussi c'est un
moyen de prévenir un problème plus grave
qui est un petit peu le harcèlement à
l'école et qui est un homme de grande
ampleur qui est aussi un problème avant
ses paroles à nice de l'éducation najat
vallaud belkacem cette année tout à fait
le harcèlement le cyber harcèlement un
qui est quelque chose qui est peut-être
encore plus difficile pour nous en tant
que personnel de direction personnels
d'éducation a ciblé parce que le cyber
harcèlement il se passe en dehors de la
sphère scolaire il se passe en dehors de
la sphère parental se passe aussi en
dehors de la sphère scolaire
on ne découvre que quand il ya
effectivement des conflits qui
apparaissent dans les établissements
scolaires le harcèlement
on le voit on peut peut-être plus
facilement le le prévenir et le traité
que le cyber harcèlement donc les
parents sont informés
en ce qui concerne les éducateurs ou les
enseignants il ya des choses qu'ils
doivent faire aussi devoir prendre en
compte des nouvelles peut-être mesure
que vous leur dispenser ils le prennent
en compte quand ils sont sensibilisés
ils sont sensibilisés
quand ils auront ils relèvent des
mal-être chez leurs élèves en tout cas
il nous les signaler nous essayons de
les traiter d'informer les familles
toujours et on essaie de remonter à la
source à chaque fois qu'on peut donc
voilà on en faisant du travail régulier
gotti quotidien oui parce que c'est
important de veiller à ce que ça ne se
propage pas c'est un des points le plus
compliqué à gérer quand on est chef
d'établissement justement ce moyen de
gérer un conflit qui au final elles
n'étaient pas visibles qui se fait sur
internet et sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est peut-être plus compliqué que que
le harcèlement
ces voix là n'a pas réussi à trouver la
source et à s'assurer que ça ne va pas
se renouveler c'est compliqué je pense
que quand les parents sont bien informés
peut-être que les choses sont moins
compliquées ce que vous avez justement
peut-être quelques conseils à donner ou
peut-être pour donner envie justement
aux parents de venir demain à cette
réunion et s'informait savoir plus que
c'est un problème qui est parfois un
petit peu négligé par les adultes alors
qu'il ya beaucoup d'importance pour les
enfants mon premier conseil c'est venez
demain vous passerez une heure très
agréable je pense avec beaucoup
d'informations et vous en retirerez
aussi des dés
des informations que vous pourrez
retrouver facilement sur le site et
enfance si vous ne pouviez pas venir
demain retenait l'adresse et enfants ce
que vous pouvez retrouver sur internet
et prenez le temps de regarder leurs
vidéos et mais je pense que c'est très
intéressant d'écouter là ce n'est pas
une conférence est très c'est très
presque ludique c'est très intéressant
merci beaucoup à janique rails alors je
le rappelle la rencontre a lieu demain
jeudi 14 janvier à 19 heures au collège
blaise pascal à plaisir et c'est la
nouveauté en ce début d'année à voisins
le bretonneux la vie vient de mettre en
place une mutuelle de village
exclusivement réservé aux habitants et
aux personnes travaillant dans la
commune objectif annoncé
faciliter l'accès aux soins avec des
tarifs préférentiels
les détails avec michael et demi d'euros
et florent lamoitte une mutuelle de
village pour faciliter l'accès aux soins
à voisins le bretonneux c'est la mesure
phare annoncée par la maire de la
commune avec son art aux eti pendant ses
voeux van ly dernier l'objectif de ce
dispositif permet trop ici noyau
personnes travaillant à voisin d'être
couverts à des tarifs préférentiels
négocié par la ville c'est souvent la
première économique les gens font sur
leurs dépenses
il supprime la mutuelle et on sait bien
que les problèmes de santé qu'on peut
avoir avoir une mutuelle c'est vraiment
capital
donc on s'est dit que en se regroupant
comme l'ont fait d'autres villes eh bien
on pourrait
je dirais être plus forts et y avoir des
bons tarifs pour développer ce projet un
questionnaire a été lancée dans la ville
pour identifier les besoins des
habitants
les frais d'hospitalisation d'optique et
soins dentaires ont été plébiscités par
les vies si noir ce qui nous intéresse
mon épouse et moi c'est le prix je
trouve que l'initiative de la mairie est
une bonne chose
cette mutuelle de couverture santé c'est
ce qui en dit long des cours
troisièmement important est de plus en
plus important chaque année et donc je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui
préoccupe beaucoup les retraités mon cas
donc voir c'est pourquoi ce dossier
m'intéresse énormément à l'issue d'un
appel d'offres la mutuelle prévoyance
des salariés mps a été retenu par la
municipalité
la cotisation mensuelle individuel
démarre à 58 euros 50 par mois pour les
50 ans et plus le tarif est à 25 euros
40 pour les moins de 30 ans disons que
la comparaison qui a été fait par
voisins-le-bretonneux ils ont trouvé nos
cotisations adapté par rapport aux
prestations contrairement aux uns des
autres à d'autres propositions qui leur
étaient faites pour plus d'informations
la mutuelle proposés permanence le
prochain rendez vous est fixé le 27
janvier prochain à la maison des
associations et nous restons sur le
thème de la santé tous les mois attrape
des rencontres sont organisées avec un
médecin sur justement le thème de la
santé pour discuter santé mardi dernier
au centre socioculturel annette moreau
attrape a eu une après midi des changes
autour de la santé de l'homme pendant
une après midi les participants ont pu
découvrir ou approfondir leurs
connaissances sur l'organe génital
masculin et son fonctionnement
un reportage signé william l c'est une
assistance exclusivement composée de
femmes qui écoutent attentivement le
docteur jacques segal parler de prostate
d'érection ou d'andropause l'objectif de
cette rencontre autour de la santé de
l'homme expliqué au public l'organe
génital masculin et son fonctionnement
est long plus d'informations sur
l'anatomie de la femme que sur
l'anatomie de l'homme et elles savent
très peu de choses sur la sexualité de
l'homme et sur les mécanismes
qui permettent les rapports sexuels
pourtant ouverte à tous ces rencontres
accueillent généralement un public
féminin venu chercher des informations
utiles qui leur permettront de mieux
comprendre leur conjoint ou leur enfant
pour beaucoup de deux femmes quelles que
soient les cultures c'est difficile de
voir des images du sexe de l'homme
d'entendre parler de comment ça
fonctionne etc mais aussi au fait ça de
façon détendue et respectueuse et bien
y'a pas de réseau non plus de véhiculer
des tabous parce que ce sont des tenants
le but du docteur segal faire tomber ses
tabous par la parole en expliquant même
certaines pathologies
au début des questions sont timides mais
toujours pertinente
un premier pas difficile mais
aujourd'hui c'est vénus qui l'a fait
vers mars
samedi 9 janvier le centre social du
pont du rotois re de clients de lui en
cours proposé une soirée interculturelle
dans le cadre d'un programme global qui
rendait hommage à aimé césaire
l'occasion de promouvoir la richesse
culturelle du territoire au travers d'un
partage de pratiques artistiques et
culinaires 9 16 associés association de
guyancourt se sont mobilisés pour
rythmer la soirée avec des spectacles de
danses percussions poésie exposition est
aussi pleine exotiques
les détails avec jeff bridges est
directeur du centre social du pont du
rotois rdée billancourt comme message
notre capacité encore à vivre ensemble
et à faire en sorte de pouvoir croiser
notre richesse
culturel qui est forcément variés vu que
les gens sur huit en cours et sur le
pont du routard sont issus d'une
certaine façon de la diversité donc ça
permet de témoigner de façon très
concrète qu'on est capable encore de
partager des moments ensemble et c'est à
présent la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis tout de suite rester
avec nous vous avez rendez vous avec
sephora namani pour le magazine culturel
kiosque quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain à la même heure pour le 7 8 le
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée